welcome to this five-minute Prince game
against Westphalia from from Germany
what else could I play hmm hmm let's
start with that and decide later I could
play a bank oh maybe you if he allows it
no see 3 yeah that's probably the most
boring move possible in this position it
just sort of prepares Bishop g5 and it's
generally very very solid ok let's see I
would love to play c5 but it might be a
gambit may be black and just stare what
can just take it ok I'm gambling on that
try to get a bit of an interesting game
going it's an interesting try for white
to capture not now because we five but
the move earlier ok so we have this
position why display an interesting move
order that still keeps them most of his
options open we are Queen B 6 queen bee
three C for Quincy to I cannot play
Bishop f5 like I 12 ok more I can play G
60 e6 these types of moves hmm ok well
keep it let's play it in a very solid
fashion which is not not bad ok
let's start with castle suspenders too
much time here this is the only real
problem position is quite quite okay
it's a well-known set up interesting so
what does he try to do I mean okay i can
i can i can take and play for you five
maybe this is a simple solution this
battery queen bee one Bishop d3 i mean
okay on h7 that's not not going to
happen much it can play maybeee forme de
Knight takes Knight takes bishop takes
and then there is a tempo on the pawn
but it's not not terribly dangerous for
me you can do that though it's not not
bad only form but I could maybe try to
play c4 okay it's not really relevant
because you played Knight to g5 yeah
well he's threatening here h6 we will
probably play night h7 looks a bit
strange but otherwise this does not make
any any sort of sense okay check ya know
I'm probably threatening a five cutting
off the bishop so it will probably
retreat he didn't retreat okay well okay
you can play f5 Bishop g6 ya can do that
I can also play g6 like right now trying
to say that that's not really great this
the sacrifice g6 Bishop g6 MFG green tea
eggs and yeah well it's not not really a
problem for for black but not clear what
how good it really is it's not bad but
ok f5 Bishop g6 yeah that's a very safe
way to play not a bad way actually I can
I have Bishop a6 as well ok let's do
that I spent like ages 4 not much
actually ok um this was what I was
trying to do I could activate this
Bishop now then even kicking this away
it's um not clear where the bishop is
supposed to go exchanging with Bishop e2
looks yeah this looks very meek but he
went for it anyway okay I need this on
c6 probably two to take the night and
once it appears on e5 okay should I play
h5 shutting everything down here it's
not terribly bad it could also try g5
not sure come on let's keep it somewhat
simple I'm really really no one time
mmm yeah but she's also spending quite
quite some time here and not quite sure
what his idea might be what I'm going to
do is to play c4b 5a five advancing on
the queenside ok this is prevented for
the moment interesting
and maybe intending c4 here I 10 still
take on c5 place before that was stupid
I do after this check i don't really
have a good good square to go to it's
really a bit awkward maybe to age 6 okay
if I take now DC if I was even attacking
of the Queen time morning that was a
clever move actually check em you're not
sure how bad it really is but tell me it
still seems fairly solid to me maybe we
can play you for something okay I can
take just with the Queen iam what is the
big problem now nothing I guess ice
quick on the c 50 channel the zone ah
this was bad yeah trying trying for
counter play of course cannot try to
keep the material
check check let's see what he does now
with this couch edition should have
retreated problem but don't care check
check check
now white is totally winning of course
but let's see if we can can really win
it look great the eighth now is quite
good check check check check jump I
cannot really do anything against the
draw check gain ground yeah this is okay
of course from a total loss but yeah
well this was bad this c4 opening of the
position was of course really terrible
for me I am after Queen B 2 of course I
need to move the thing simply and then I
think there's simply nothing going on I
can just go in somewhere like here Queen
here to here maybe and then I don't know
it's so closed maybe white can still
play with c4 I don't know okay well the
problem is this is probably the move h5
which is really a very very unambitious
between just trying to block it because
I try to what's a little time make it
let's say try to make easier to play
moves but then Hector it's it's probably
not the right decision I mean I can I
can't play a trial anytime if I want to
close it down I can start with that now
and prevent all this b3 business I can
can play other stuff I wasn't even
thinking about g5 here which is not so
terrible it takes and then then try try
from here it's not so so great here
let's say Ruby Jade this is sound quite
interesting i have
as well but okay I was on one minute
something and I didn't want to do it
like so complicated stuff but with with
h5 this this now got got really tricky
especially here what dc5 was of course
also possible probably even better when
what am i doing after that check yeah
that's just bad i mean this is this is
certainly not a good formation when the
position opens up it's not a big deal
with it being totally closed but yeah
now i just get into this into this
rotten endgame check yeah maybe I can
defend it better with him it's probably
your loss in any case it's just so
passive checkity I'm totally scared of
course oops sorry the questions chatting
Jesse did is probably okay our look the
eight is not winning okay that's
surprised that I thought this would win
probably I mean white has all the time
in the world I can I guess Utley have no
big big ideas here then play let's say
you form ok I can I can go here but
let's let's say something like that and
I'm zoosk want really it's not I cannot
really do anything here Ruby to this e
for King 87 it's going to go here this
is this a threat yeah well it's just
it's just lost here and this seems to be
a shia drawn in fact I've got enough
Carl to play the important thing is of
course the root g 7 is failing simply
due to that or all this change this so
this is a loss right yeah this is a loss
but I can just take on g 3 which is very
important covering here you can play
that
the mid and this is check getting to
this perpetual in another way okay
thanks for watching